hypothetical question for you
what if frogs ruled the earth
not just in terms of numbers but in
terms of their position in the ecosystem
amphitera is a speculative biology
project by the talented artist and
writer roxy valdez which imagines the
incredible and surreal forms frogs might
achieve if given the perfect environment
to evolve while the world of amphitera
often looks like an alien planet the
artist imagines it's actually an
alternate timeline of earth where subtly
different climatic conditions led to
early amphibians out-competing the first
dinosaurs in proto-mammals what
creatures will develop and thrive in
this drastically different history
for this entry into the archive we'll be
exploring the fascinating possibilities
of the amphitera project and remember to
support roxy valdez on patreon using the
links below if you're a fan of this
project
now let's leap back
252 million years and begin our tour
through the timeline of amphitera
our epic tale of frog ascendancy begins
in the early triassic with the oldest
member of the frog lineage the
diminutive triadobatracus this amphibian
is present in our timeline as well but
in the alternate world of amphitera the
wetter damper conditions will lead
triadobatracus to be better suited for
the period than early synapsids and
reptiles as a result its descendants
will rise to the top of this primordial
earth
by the late triassic in what is now
nigeria the common eofrog has emerged
from the triada petrakus and represents
the first major deviation from our world
brought on by the ideal conditions of
this alternate timeline the eofrog is
essentially just a big frog but over
many eons it will provide the anatomical
basis for the most significant species
of this alternate reality the reign of
the amphibians has now begun
by the early jurassic the descendants of
the eofrog have evolved to fill various
major niches across the ecosystems of
the world
in the marshy plains an effective
predator has emerged in the form of the
amusingly named greater moist boy while
these life forms have a comical
appearance the advance they represent is
tremendous having brought their limbs
under their body to be taller and faster
than their competition
the moist boy also possesses an enlarged
clavicular ring which essentially
functions like a rib cage and help
support their growing weight many of the
most successful predators of the future
will branch off from this design
in the rain forest of what is now
northern africa the marbled snap apple
perches on a branch this early tree
dweller has evolved a creeping
unpredictable form of movement
convergent with our timeline's
chameleons and will serve as the
foundation for various unusual offshoots
already it is becoming more sedentary a
lifestyle that will continue until it
reaches truly extreme levels
in the forest of what is now eastern
africa another major tree climbing
species has emerged in the lanky frogget
while they still spend some time on the
forest floor these thin long-legged
organisms are expert climbers patiently
navigating from branch to branch even
more than the snap apple the froggit's
descendants will be the champions of the
world's canopies
and the last major niche filled is that
of the grazing herbivore which is
currently occupied by the lowland dogus
these herd-dwelling lifeforms are the
cousins of the greater moist boy and
have similarly made the critical
advancement of raising their frame off
the ground a wide range of future
herbivorous megafauna will owe their
evolutionary ancestry to the dogus as
the various eofrog descendants continue
to diversify and expand in number
on the dry plains of the cretaceous
period a mighty predator comes to rule
the bull pronks are the descendants of
the greater moist boy and have become
efficient pack predators they hunt
grazing animals in coordinated prides
much like lions in our modern day
to communicate while on patrol the bull
pronks can raise and lower their tails
like signal flags and even flush them
with color
these tales are actually a retained
trait from their tadpole stage showing
these lifeforms have had to get creative
to take over niches typically
unassociated with amphibians
and speaking of getting creative in the
misty rainforests of the north the
mottled sucker lump is a creature whose
specialized lifestyle has caused a
tremendous shift in its body plan even
more than their ancestors the marbled
snap apples these animals are incredibly
inactive with some spending their entire
adult life rooted to a single branch
like an amphibious barnacle as with our
timeline's flatfish their anatomy seems
absurd yet is actually perfectly suited
for their methods of survival the sucker
lumps lifestyle requires few calories so
they can subsist on insects that come
into range of their projectile tongue
and with their characteristic mottled
coloring they can hide effectively from
their prey until it's too late
and further along into the cretaceous
and even stranger variant of the sucker
lump will emerge under the waves the
tropical frondal can be found nestled in
underwater shallows and has a truly
bizarre lifestyle beginning as a free
swimming tadpole once they mature they
never develop limbs becoming completely
stationary filter feeders this lifestyle
requires very little brain power so like
the soft-bodied sea squirts of our
timeline the tropical frondal shockingly
digests most of their brains upon
reaching adulthood repurposing the
valuable proteins elsewhere the
frondal's most characteristic adult
feature is their highly derived tongue
which has evolved sticky branches to
catch the planktonic organisms the
frontal survives on at this point in the
timeline some creatures have clearly
become unrecognizable as amphibians
and high in the treetops around the same
period a frog with an equally bizarre
body plan makes its home the tree frixel
is the descendant of the lanky frogget
the other tree-dwelling specialists that
emerged alongside the snap apple the
tree frixel is even better adapted for
the trees however with a body plan that
at first seems implausibly awkward but
makes perfect sense when the tree friczl
is in its element like our primates the
tree frixl swings through the canopy
above with their hind limbs perfectly
positioned to navigate from branch to
branch as this biomechanical
visualization illustrates as a result
the tree frictions have developed thumb
like digits in a general rise in
cognitive ability given time they may
give rise to something truly special
one relative of the frixel will take a
very different path than its tree
climbing cousins in the force of our
timeline central america you might spot
a gliding aloo thus far in the
infibiteren timeline amphibians have yet
to conquer the skies in the way our
birds or bats have as the ectothermic
low metabolism bodies of amphibians
aren't well equipped for the rigors of
powered flight but the aloo has found a
loophole to hunt it climbs up trees and
uses eyes rotated almost to the back of
its head to calculate the distance of
its prey once a target is locked the elu
leaps back first towards the forest
floor using primitive wings in a
specialized sack that inflates to
provide drag to slow its descent as
bizarre as the alu strategy might seem
it is not unlike the early dinosaurs
like archaeopteryx in our own timeline
that achieved flight the future may yet
hold skies dominated by the eluz
curiously inverted descendants
speaking of curious descendants at the
very end of the cretaceous period the
arid grasslands will give rise to a
creature so bizarre it's at first
difficult to comprehend
this is an inhabited lord a slow bulky
herbivore that is the descendant of the
lowland dogus at a glance the
slow-moving lords might seem vulnerable
to predation but the lorge has its own
private security in the form of the
colonial gobelins a species that have
evolved to live within the lord's hump
the tiny goblins are actually another
branch of the banded sucker lump's
unusual family tree and they've
developed a close symbiotic relationship
with their living nests at the first
sign of danger the goblin horde will
exit the lords and swarm an attacker
until it backs off it's an effective
strategy yet this highly specialized
pairing won't have many offshoots going
forward in a changing world
get another descendant of the lowland
dogus will continue on upon the cold
tundra of the early tertiary period one
amphibian has found an ingenious way to
survive the cold the foaming squander
lives farther north than most amphibian
megafauna can exist yet the squander
stays warm thanks to its eponymous foam
specialized pores on the squander's back
produce a thick towering covering of
insulating foam this foam is similar to
the mucous coating some frogs in our
timeline produce to keep their skin
moist the squander's foam is unique
however as it traps heat within its
structure allowing the squander to roam
the polar reaches with this clever
adaptation descendants of the squander
will be well equipped for the cooling
climate
to the south another species that will
have many successful descendants
dominates the dry step
the stepfragon is a carnivorous behemoth
distantly related to the nimble pack
hunting plane's bullprong now highly
territorial the massive steppe fragon no
longer has a need for a pack hunting all
on its own
but the stepfragon is actually an
omnivore with a lifestyle that could be
compared to a bear gorging itself to
build fat for winter hibernation as the
planet continues to cool the fragons
will endure and will diversify in
unexpected ways
but one creature whose fate is more
mysterious inhabits the trees of
temperate environments high in the
canopy the astonishing freepole live in
elevated wooden villages a descendant of
the tree frixel freeple have achieved a
level of intelligence roughly analogous
to a human like male frigate birds under
their chin freepl have a highly
developed goal or sac for communication
but frequent communication is highly
complex with their language almost
comparable to a curious form of morris
code even more curiously it seems the
freeple vanished from the infibiteren
timeline several million years after
their evolution what fate befilled these
enigmatic creatures did they die out or
given time reach a level of advancement
that allowed for a different kind of
exit we have no way to say for sure but
no matter the nature of their departure
the freeple's absence makes room for
even stranger
species by the late tertiary an isolated
island environment has given rise to a
stunning life-form the splendid fragon
is a descendant of the steppe fragon
that has become a peaceful herbivore
spending its day wading through swampy
jungles on graceful stilt-like legs with
a vibrant coloring a splendid fragon
silently picking their way through their
island home would likely be a
magnificent sight they feed on mushrooms
that grow in this region in abundance
foregoing the omnivorous lifestyle of
their ancestor
on the mainland however another fragon
descendant has taken the opposite path
the catastrophic fragon is the largest
land-dwelling carnivore the world of
amphitera has ever seen the catastrophic
fragon's rotund anatomy might seem
surprising at a glance as it almost
looks too bulky to be able to stand yet
examining the animal skeleton the fragon
center of gravity is a clavicular ring
that began over developing all the way
back in the greater moist boy this ring
acts as the linchpin to the fragon's
massive bulk while the catastrophic
fragon's reign is amazing it's also
rather short an impending drop in
temperature will cause the age of the
fragon to end prematurely
yet one type of fragon already well
adapted to the cold will live on the
arctic fragon thrives into the late
tertiary protected from the cold thanks
to layers of blubber and a thick hide
its most unique adaptation to stay warm
however is the thick coating of fur on
its underside
these hairs are actually dermal
palpillae tubes of skin and fatty tissue
that trap warm air against the fragon's
body much like fur
and since the amphiteren ice age is
imagined to be less severe than our own
the arctic fragons have all they need to
continue to thrive
but there are other ways of surviving
the cold a short distance south the eon
toad are a species with a very different
method of enduring the long winter
months the eon toad is actually a
descendant of the foaming squander that
has traded its foaming coat for
something even stranger eon toads enter
a state of hibernation that can last
multiple years enduring periods of minor
freezing and unfreezing as it waits for
the perfect spring to become active
again while this type of cold protection
is rarely seen in an animal some plants
contain cryo-protectors that stop their
cells from lethal shrinkage while they
allow themselves to be frozen solid for
long periods
and on the subject of plants the eon
toad will often wake to find many types
of vegetation have grown over its body
which can be harmful if left unchecked
and in the same region the final species
of this timeline can be found which
serve as an example of just how alien
the fauna of amphitera can be
the foaming troggle folk are another
descendant of the foaming squander which
are quite a bit smaller than their
ancestors
incredibly trouble folk live in villages
constructed from their characteristic
foam which frees into solid structures
due to the cold they're also highly
communal sculpting the foam on the
bodies of family members into regionally
distinct styles this social grooming
behavior is not unlike that of certain
primates in our timeline and shows an
emerging intelligence
indeed certain communities of trouble
folk have begun cultivating edible
fungus within their nest demonstrating
the beginnings of agriculture like the
fruit before them the troglo folks may
rise to incredible heights
over the course of this journey we've
seen pseudo-frogs rise and fall evolve
incredible adaptations and fulfill
unexpected niches but now we must return
to our own timeline where frogs though
not quite as abundant are still quite
wonderful if you enjoyed learning about
amphitera as much as i did you can
support roxy valdez on patreon and
social media using the links in the
description
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you